israël tournée l'ancien premier ministre
avait 80 ans la transat une épave
repérer sur l'atlantique ce pourrait
être manureva on ne sait pas si alain
colas est à bord la flambée des impôts
locaux ils ont doublé en quelques années
le mécontentement des contribuables la
chine qui s'éveille et qui s'ouvre à
l'occident le témoignage de l'envoyée
spéciale d'antenne de patrick clément
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir avant de parler avec vous de la
mort de golda meir cette grande dame de
la politique israélienne
il me faut tout d'abord vous parler
d'alain colas les nouvelles que j avoue
données sont dramatiques
mais elles sont encore à prendre au
conditionnel voilà les faits en milieu
d'après midi un pétrolier panaméen qui
croise au large des açores au nord-ouest
annonce avoir repéré une épave
on le sent blanc oman où rêve mais le
pétrolier qui ne sait même pas déroutés
pour aller voir le nom du bateau qui
semblait dérivé sans personne à bord
le pétrolier n'en dit pas plus il nous
apprend simplement que le voilier à 2
manoir ce qui correspond au signalement
du bateau d'alain colas aussitôt bien
sûr les recherches par avion se porte
sur ce point précis de l'atlantique
un avion a décollé il y a trois heures
environs de brest
il devrait survoler l'épave dans les
minutes qui vont suivre peut-être même
en ce moment même et donc pouvoir en
direct dans ce journal
confirmé ou infirmé la nouvelle en
attendant bien sûr nous n'avons pas le
droit de céder au catastrophisme
vous allez voir dans ce reportage que
nous avions réalisée au moment du
lancement du manureva que alain colas
avait tout prévu en cas d'accident à
bord lorsque l'on souhaite avoir des
performances de vitesse
c'est le bateau idéal maintenant quand
il s'agit d'entreprendre des traversées
très longue et difficile dans des
conditions
dur de gros temps de forte brise il ya
danger il ya danger qu'il ne chavire et
à ce moment là il reste à l'envers c'est
plus qu'un quart à dos à la dérive il
s'agissait avant tout de caporaliser le
bateau alors les moustaches à l'avant
j'avais eu l'occasion dans d'autres
navigation devenu partir en fuite dans
du gros temps de l'arrière et je m'étais
rendu compte de ce grand danger pour le
multicoque d'engager l'avant dans le
creux d'une vague tandis que l'arrière
est soulevée soulevé soulevé jusqu'au
risque de tout le but est ce qu'on a
rapporté à la vente et des flatteurs et
de la coque centrale
c'est un peu comme ce que peut être là
la spatule pour le ski on l'a on a
spatule et l'avant du bateau sur les
conseils d'un navigateur dada copa
navigateur qui rentrait du cap horn loïc
fougeron j'ai ménagé dans le fond du
bateau une trappe boulonnais de
l'intérieur avec des projets propres et
fillon est un outil spécial pour voir où
est très vite et si le bateau avec tout
de même que la culbute par là j'aurais
pu me dégager avoir de l'air installer
une antenne radio de secours et elle me
débrouiller quoi tenter quelque chose
oui si comme nous disent certaines
dépêches toujours d'après le témoignage
de ce pétrolier panaméen si donc comme
nous le disent certaines dépêches le
manureva c'est bien retourné de la sorte
il ya donc vous le voyez encore un petit
espoir
souhaitons lui en tout cas un sort aussi
heureux que celui d'aline marchands dont
on était également son nouvel et qui
vient d'arriver à la guadeloupe
après donc avoir échappé à toutes les
recherches qui pourtant été déclenchée à
quelques milles de sa position est donc
deux inconnus ce soir le sort du
guadeloupéen jacques pallas et et celui
d'alain colas à tout moment bien sûr
nous pouvons et allons tout journal dès
qu'une information nous parviennent
golda mère est morte et morte voilà
plusieurs semaines que madame mère avait
été hospitalisée mais son état n'a
investi s'est aggravée voilà mr je crois
que c'était vraiment une grande dame
la boutade de tel-aviv s'est fait même
de dire que c'était le seul vrai homme
d'israël une boutade en forme d'hommage
bien sûr un hommage à cette femme née à
kiev en russie il y à 80 ans et premier
ministre d'israël pendant cinq ans à une
époque très difficile notamment pendant
la guerre des six jours
son dernier bonheur aura peut-être été
une poignée de main historique avec
anouar al sadate
mais il lui a manqué sans doute le plus
beau des cadeaux finale l'a fait la fai
qui traînent les pieds au proche orient
celle qui était devenue la grand mère
terry d'israël a consacré toute sa vie
au sionisme et à la création d'israël
militant acharné en urss aux états unis
elle émigre en palestine en 1921
c'est avec ben gourion qu elle forge sa
véritable vie politique pendant des
années à la sa ble ment elle parcourt le
monde pour exposer la thèse du sionisme
et la nécessité d'un foyer national juif
qui devient en 1948 l'état d'israël
en 1969 elle accepte le poste de premier
ministre
sa forte personnalité va marquer
indéniablement la vie politique
internationale
mais pour les israéliens golda restera
peut-être dans l'histoire comme le
premier ministre qui dut affronter la
guerre d'octobre 73 une épreuve
dramatique où les premiers jours le
destin d'israël failli basculer
je savais que nous étions engagés dans
une guerre terrible causerie web parce
que nous n'étions pas préparés
aucune foi de peste
j'espérais que ça se passerait pour le
mieux mais je savais que deux jeunes
hommes auraient visité là-bas en train
de ce bar ont dit que leur corps c'est
un contre les chars d'assaut vers les
ouvriers team pour être abandonné à
l'onf et que ça je ne crois pas je
n'abandonne pas facilement sa ténacité
et est légendaire elle t'a fait souvent
du point au cours des conseils des
ministres et à la knesset
sa ténacité était quand même brisé après
cette guerre d'octobre
elle fut accusée comme son ministre de
la défense le général moshe dayan de
négligence d'avoir mal préparé l'armée
d'israël elle dû assumer les défaits des
premiers jours et quitter la vie
politique
cependant de réparer en novembre 77 il y
à peine un an pour la visite du
président sadate à jérusalem
c'était son adversaire pendant la guerre
d'octobre réconciliation qu'elles
avaient attendu toute sa vie saine
particulièrement émouvante où elle dit à
sa date
voici le cadeau d'une grand-mère à un
grand père le président saad al vient
d'avoir un petit fils aller de l'avant
je veux voir avant de mourir la paix
s'établit entre
pas du tout
et c'est à oslo que menahem begin a
appris la mort de golda mère qui occupe
à son poste deux ans avant lui donnerai
mes guînes venait d'arriver en norvège
pour se faire remettre le prix de la
paix que lui ont décerné le nobel
conjointement avec anouar al sadate mais
anouar el sadate n'est pas là il n'en
voyaient oslo qu'un collaborateur
c'est dire que la paix est en panne
entre égyptiens et israéliens il y a
bien peu de chances d'aboutir à la
signature d'un traité avant le 17
décembre comme l'a souhaité jimmy carter
hier soir dans une déclaration assez
ferme
le caire et jérusalem at il dit ferait
une grave erreur en ne signant pas avant
cette date
jimmy carter qui par ailleurs a évoqué
les événements iraniens en déclarant
pour la première fois qu'il ne savait
pas si le chat pourrait se maintenir au
pouvoir
jamais monsieur carter n'avait exprimé
pareille attitude il avait jusqu'alors
toujours soutenu le chat il faut dire
que l'iran se prépare à vivre une très
dure fin de semaine à la proche des
cérémonies religieuses de l'ashoura et
c'est sans doute dans cette perspective
que le chat vient de faire libérer
233 prisonniers politiques ils le seront
dimanche à l'occasion de la journée des
droits de l'homme mais dans le même
temps ils en faisaient part étaient
plusieurs dizaines d'autres
depuis le début de la crise iranienne le
trafic des passagers était certes
important à l'aéroport de téhéran
mais à mesure que l'on approche de
dimanche le début de la célébration des
solennités religieuses islamiques de la
place soit de la shoah l'aéroport est
littéralement su bien après avoir
d'abord fait interdire toute
manifestation hier dans des communiqués
lus à la radio et à la télévision
le gouvernement iranien est finalement
revenu sur sa décision et les fidèles
pourront s'ils le veulent descendre dans
la rue plutôt que de rechercher
l'affrontement le gouvernement iranien
préfère donc laisser faire l'armée
encore fidèles au chah est attentive
quant à l'opposition il semble qu'elle
veuille réunir toutes ces forces ces
jours là dans une démonstration massive
d'hostilité au régime couronnement des
manifestations quotidiennes comme celle
ce hier à washington donc le président
carter n'a pas caché son pessimisme
quant à l'avenir du chat dimanche et
lundi deux jours cruciaux pour le chat
et pour vivre
pour l'ipad en ce sujet mme arrivé
beaucoup d g de condoléances pour golda
meir d'abord celui du président
république française le giscard
d'estaing qui estime qu'avec mme adam
gould amer c'est une des grandes figures
de l'histoire israélienne qui disparaît
elle appartenait dit-il à la génération
des pionniers en ayant partagé les
épreuves les luttes et la joie
télégramme de condoléances également de
françois mitterrand qui souligne la
place irremplaçable que madame golda
meir laisse dans le mouvement socialiste
international kg également du président
carter qui estiment qu'elle était le
symbole du courage et de l'idéalisme de
l'esprit d'israël
dernier événement en provenance de
l'étranger et qui lui intéresse aussi
très directement le président carter
wakin d'asie bao en chine donc une de
ses affiches murales dans lesquelles les
chinois s'exprime en ce moment les tant
de fougue un des ziban aux docks a lancé
un appel à jimmy carter et au congrès
mecque pour qu'ils s'occupent de l'état
des droits de l'homme en chine
le daisy bao a disparu peu de temps
après les tout de même la venue de
shanghai en plein centre et pékin il ya
deux jours c'est dans cette avenue que
courent ce très long mur ap le mur de la
démocratie mur de la démocratie parce
que c'est surtout sa surface que les
pékinois cole et dazibao et sédative ce
sont ces affiches murales ou journaux
mureaux à travers lesquelles un individu
ou un groupe communique avec la mars
l'apparition de ces d'adibawa donc n'est
pas nouvelle ce qui en revanche est
nouveau c'est leur contenu depuis
quelques temps très respectueuse vont
mais très fermement
on critique la pensée du président
mortiers tourne depuis quelques temps
réclament plus de démocratie des
élections libres du thym secret et la
pensée du plan noté tout y est même
chiffrée on a pu lire qu'elle était
bonne à 70% et mauvaises à 30% alors
patrick tellement vous revenez d'une
très longue enquête en chine est ce que
vous avez ressenti concrètement cela
bouillonnement de la démocratie en ce
moment oui ne pas là évidemment presque
normal mais stupéfiant quand on se place
du côté chinois pour nous aucun oui mais
avec ado le faisandé christian quérou on
a pu constater d'abord qu'en chine chose
qu'on savait on dit
mais ni oui ni non 30 jamais alors c'est
un événement extraordinaire
effectivement que l'on puisse lire aux
yeux de tous sur les murs du pékin des
critiques presque deux ans et demi après
la mort du président mao tsé toung des
critiques qui sont signés avec surtout
le numéro de la carte de travail donc
des critiques n'ont absolument pas non
donc tu veux réparer notre année ou
disons légèrement poussé c'est difficile
et très difficile de répondre à cette
question disons que encore une fois
après deux ans et demi il après deux ans
et demi de la disparition est présent en
boîte c'est tout on peut lire dans la
presse ça c'est très important qu'aucun
parti n'est aucune personne est
infaillible ça c'est à peine voilée
contre le fait qu'il emmènerait c' est
ce qu'on peut parler de démobilisation
écoutez comme new york n'est pas les
états unis tout l'été tous les états
unis pékin n'est pas tout la chine c'est
la vérité ceci étant il n'empêche que en
chine toutes ces dernières années tous
les événements sont partis de pékin pour
se pendre à une vitesse vertigineuse
dans toute la chine est touchée
tout d'un coup 980 chinois maintenant il
faut voir comment les chinois acceptent
ce que l'on lézardes dans la pensée du
présent dossier tout mais pour résumer
en quelques mots
adolphe et de christien et ouais moi
même on a parcouru la chine ne sont au
rsa sont sud assure près de 8000
kilomètres et on a pu constater une
chose essentielle c'est que les mots
liberté et démocratie sont valables ici
mais ils sont aussi valables ailleurs là
bas bien patrick que s'il montrait et
crise à irun donc nous feront part de
leurs adolphe blessures et six chrétiens
irun nous feront part de leurs voyages à
de multiples reprises dans ce journal
et puis surtout à l'intérieur d'un
magazine que nous allons composer sur
cette chine qui bouge si vite mais je
vous propose d'écouter tout de suite
l'intérieur du vice premier ministre
ghiz c'est la première fois qu'un homme
de ce rang accorde une interview au
journal occidentale et cela même valu à
notre équipe de passer à la télévision
chinoise comme vous voyez ce qui est une
manière d'honorer le travail de nos
reporters alors question de patrick
clément à monsieur fendi vous venez de
signer un très gros contrat avec les
français mais est ce que les uns
d'huriel de notre pays sont vraiment
compétitifs notamment en matière de prix
le karité enquête sur la conduite à
tenir au minimum opposante au commis non
jlg ans autour d'un surcroît
mais moi mon rôle inconscient trône oui
l'avertissement est clair visiblement
concurrence du marché c'est valable en
chine comme en occident
un attentat à l'explosif en corse
aveyron près d'ajaccio le responsable de
la sécurité civile de la corse du sud a
été grièvement blessé pas plus de
détails pour l'instant sidérurgie 8000
licenciements prévus à facile or cela
que voilà ce qu'annonce la cfdt
il pense que la nouvelle sera rendu
public au cours de la réunion du comité
d'entreprise de la société le 15
décembre et pendant ce temps vallourec
confirmé la mise en préretraite de 320
personnes
mais annonce qu'elle va investir 1
milliard de francs dans le nord
notamment à maubeuge à valenciennes
un programme qui va contribuer à
préserver l'emploi de dix mille
personnes dans un secteur en crise
manufrance c'est bien la réunion du
comité d'entreprise a été très brève
mais en prenant du personnel ont refusé
d'entendre la communication du pdg
françois gado clé ils l'accusent de
sabotage économique
une innovation de taille adoptée par les
apprennent par les députés cet
après-midi sous certaines conditions la
durée hebdomadaire du travail pour être
répartis sous quatre jours
en tout cas elle ne devra pas dépasser
dix heures par jour
et puis second point de ce projet de loi
la durée maximale du travail et ramener
de 52 heures à 50 heures pendant ce
temps les sénateurs eux travailler sur
le budget de la radiotélévision après
les critiques du sénateur caillavet et
le rapport - sever plus nuancé de son
collègue jean cluzel et bien jean
philippe lecat
le ministe de la communication devait
intervenir pour rendre hommage à ce
travail d'invention vaincu que la radio
et la télévision française
où puis-je dire font un effort constant
de cannes messieurs de cuttoli avec
émotion évoqué la voix de la france
c'est à dire ce que radio france
internationale fait dans le monde et si
nous comparons ce que font nos
télévisions à ce qui est fait dans le
monde
le spectacle est pas forcément sont
aussi dramatique
il est parfois de coutumes de l'époque
personne je prendrai qu'un exemple en
italie il existe deux chaînes de
télévision nationales et des dizaines de
chaînes de télévision privées bien tous
les italiens qui le peuvent y compris
ceux qui ne connaissent pas le français
qui regardent antennes ne le savons
c'est une anecdote mais cela veut bien
dire
néanmoins qu' à travers des difficultés
notre système de télévision grâce au
personnel de différentes catégories qui
travaillent réussi une oeuvre qui
globalement est bonne et c'est vrai
quand on donne beaucoup regarder de
l'autre côté des alpes
et j'en profite pour saluer nos amis
italiens qu'ils écrivent très souvent
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle à vous
donner
pendant ce sujet pendant que monsieur le
cas parler
j'apprends que ce n'est pas à manureva
qui a été repéré c'est en tout cas le
commandant navale des açores qui donc a
visiblement survolé il ya quelques
minutes
les papes dont je vous parlais au tout
début du journal qui vient de l'indiquer
un sos savez débit lancée jeudi par à un
voilier deux mailles ne s'agirait donc
pas de manureva je pense que nous aurons
davantage d'informations dans le cours
de ce journal pas manureva c'est à dire
le bateau d'alain colas bien sûr et puis
pendant que ceux discutés ce budget de
la radiotélévision le comité
d'entreprise de la ssp se réunissaient
pour examiner les grandes lignes du plan
proposé par son pdg bertrand labrusse
pas d'informations pour le moment non
plus lucien neuwirth ce député rpr de la
loire se met en congé de vote de son
groupe à l'assemblée et ce à la suite de
ce qu'il appelle le coup d'éclat de
monsieur chirac
lucien neuwirth parle de choix issus de
foucades d'incompatibilité d'humeur et
d'ambition
la cote du prêt dans ma public et du
premier ministre en hausse de 3 points
indique la sofres dans le figaro
magazine qui sera publié demain 62% de
confiance pour valéry giscard d'estaing
44% pour raymond barre mais encore pour
ce dernier 49% de défiance de visiteurs
à l'elysée aujourd'hui pierre elliott
trudeau le numéro un canadien et
mustapha kabyle le premier ministre
égyptien contribué à la tension vous
avez jusqu'au 15 décembre pour acquitter
vaud
impôts locaux en partie là donc en
particulier la taxe d'habitation
ces petites feuilles jaunes que vous
reçoit cette année eh bien vous savez
vous êtes sans doute aperçu que ces
fameux impôts locaux avaient
singulièrement augmenté cette année
surtout à tel point que dans certaines
villes les contribuables ne sont pas du
tout contents ils s'organisent un
exemple suresnes dans les hauts-de-seine
ray park c'est la faute de l'état
tu ne veux pas demandé à l'ensemble d'un
cinéma à suresnes 3 400 contribuables
sont venus crier que la taxe plus
d'habitations a suffisamment augmenté
chez eux
elle s'est accrue de 50 % en deux ans
deuxième motion l'association mieux
vivre assure elle demande que
l'augmentation des impôts locaux ne
dépasse en aucun cas l'augmentation du
coût de la vie et que la mairie définit
ses dépenses en conséquence
suresnes n'est pas une exception partout
en france c'est la flambée des impôts
locaux
en cinq ans les sommes versées par les
français ou type mais de la taxe
d'habitation par exemple ont été
multipliées par deux les impôts locaux
dont le taux est fixé par le conseil
municipal servent à financer les
équipements de la commune écoles voirie
crespy cible etc
mais malgré les augmentations les maires
grenier tempête autant que leurs
administrés parce qu'ils manquent de
ressources seront de l'ensemble de la
masse fiscales perçues dans ce pays par
tous les impôts taxes et diverses 1 17%
à peu près de tout ce qui est perçu je
crois que même si c'est un peu moins de
17 % le solde
c'est à dire 83% va directement dans les
caisses de l'état mais dans le même
temps cette répartition donc déjà
inégale et injuste puisque c'est nous
qui assume ont pu 70 % de l'ensemble de
l'équipement national de l'équipement du
pays dans tous les domaines
mais dans le même temps l'état ajoute à
cette inégalité première toute une série
d' inégalité seconde en ce sens qui nous
oblige à supporter des dépenses que
précédemment une supportés au titre du
budget de l'état les 17 millions de
contribuables qui paient la taxe
d'habitation eux lui font trois
critiques principales 1
elle ne tient pas compte des ressources
du contribuable à logements égale une
veuve ou un chômeur paie autant qu'un
cadre supérieur 2
elle est trop complexe il est quasiment
impossible de comprendre comment les
services fiscaux calcule la surface et
la valeur locative résultats déceler une
erreur ou une omission sur la feuille
jaune est une affaire de détective 3
enfin certaines associations et
notamment la confédération syndicale du
cadre de vie dénonce le taux
d'imposition des logements sociaux hlm
et jelen ils ont mis tous les immeubles
neufs dans le même sac si on peut dire
et ils les ont ranger dans une catégorie
la catégorie 4 et nous pensons que c'est
contraire
ra certaines circulaires administratives
c'est contre surtout à la justice et
nous avons fait toute une série de
réclamations un dossier collectif de
réclamation on s'en est aperçu parce que
des gens venaient à nos permanences et
payer une taxe manifestement trop élevé
pour le logement qu'ils ont le syndicat
du cadre de la pluie vient de porter l
affaire devant le tribunal administratif
c'est une première juridique 2500 hlm et
jelen du xiiie arrondissement sont
concernés il avait déjà enregistré une
première victoire à caen où les services
fiscaux ont diminué de 17 à 20 % la
valeur locative 2358 hlm ce dossier donc
la réforme de la fiscalité locale
préparé par le gouvernement à la demande
de valérie ce destin sera examiné par le
parlement à la prochaine session de
printemps
mettre au monde un enfant les met toutes
ses forces et découvrir par la suite que
ce bébé est une fille alors qu'elle
croyait avoir donné le jour un garçon
celle aventure que vient de vivre une
jeune maman en france enquête analyse
devraient rétablir la situation
alors ça dit est ce un cas isolé bernard
maquis qui a mené son enquête pense que
oui il n'y a pratiquement pas d'exemple
de substitution d'enfants en france il
ne peut pas y en avoir
les méthodes de direction paraissent
infaillible lepesqueux l'accouchement ne
se fait plus à la maison a surgi la
crainte d'une substitution d'enfants
mais les précautions prises ont fait
leurs preuves à l'instant même de la
naissance l'enfant est montré à sa mère
qui en connaît ainsi le sexe puis c'est
l'inscription au registre officiel
numéro de la naissance qui correspond au
numéro du dossier de la mer date et
heure noms et prénoms sexe ces mêmes
indications sont portés sur un bracelet
à gauche et à un bras droit et de plus
les bras s'ils sont vérifiés par la
maman c'est à dire que l'enfant étant
encore dans la chambre de la
sur son ventre on lui présente les
bracelets et on les passe ensuite à
chaque bras de l'enfant
voilà deux brevets dans les deux sens
est identique pour les couleurs
correspondant enceinte
je pense que là ça correspond donc à la
maison qui nous fournit les bracelets et
qui a donné d'elle-même une couleur bleu
pour les garçons et rose éventuellement
pour les filles mais on pourrait tout à
fait mettre des papiers blancs le mandat
public n'oblige pas à faire le point sur
son nom un bracelet rose pour bien sur
le sable si cependant pour une raison
quelconque subsistait le moindre doute
la science a aujourd'hui les moyens
d'établir avec certitude de liens du
sang saisie par voie judiciaire les
experts pourront déterminer la filiation
ce que vous voyez sur la carte haguenau
leurs deux sens et par exemple ou en rh
positif ça représente deux systèmes de
barker simplement
or actuellement nous devons définir les
individus humains à l'aide de 25
opérations différentes dont celles là ne
représente que deux d'entre elles nous
avons les groupes sanguins sont bien
connus du public ni à la 15e en fait
nous avons les crocs dans les protéines
du sérum qui diffère aussi d un individu
à l'autre
nous avons des groupes dans les enzymes
globules rouges qui diffère indique
et nous avons les comptes titulaires
dont le à chaleur est un petit peu
premier public puisqu'il a un rôle par
les transplantations rénales et bien
toutes ces catégories là on nous
permettent de reconnaître un individu
d'un autre et bien entendu connaissant
ainsi la caractéristique génétique de la
mer les caractéristiques génétiques de
l'enfant
les caractéristiques génétiques du père
si l'enfant n'est pas celui de cette mer
là c'est tout à fait peu probable que
nous ne voyons pas par 2 3 4 5 des
systèmes que nous allons explorer c'est
donc la définition de l'individu qui est
remarquablement précis maintenant et qui
permet que nous pouvons reconnaître
individus parmi 700 millions à 800
millions pour les cas les plus courants
comme promis des détails sur ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure à propos de
l'épave repérer qui n'est donc pas c'est
sûr maintenant celle du manureva ce
serait celle d'un yacht anglais dont le
seul occupant à bord avait lancé un sos
et ce navigateur a été récupéré ce matin
par un bateau indonésien décès du jeune
allemand blessé par le prince victor
emmanuel de savoie
le jeune étudiante 19 ans qui ça fait
dix rameurs avait été grièvement blessée
l'été dernier en corse d'un coup de
fusil
transporté à l'hôpital de heidelberg il
avait dû être amputé d'une jambe et cinq
mois après le drame il était toujours
hospitalisé dix rameurs et donc mort
hier soir démocratisation ce sera le
leitmotiv d'air france et de son pdg
pierre giraud des mises en place en
effet d'avions spéciaux des boeing 747 à
500 places
actuellement ils ne sont que 350 places
et puis surtout la baisse de certains
tarifs à titre d'exemple paris londres
actuellement 700 francs coûtera 400
francs au printemps prochain
restons dans les verres avec un
anniversaire celui de la naissance de la
patrouille de france il ya 25 ans et à
cette occasion l'armée de l'air est
édité le magnifique livre que voici
fanatique de comédie musicale
ginger rogers est à mes côtés a invité
paris luxe pour être la vedette sur un
thème de du show du 1er janvier
ginger rogers a fait un crochet par
paris alors essayons d'abord de nous
rafraîchir
souvenirs de cinéphiles et surgissent
alors les noms de top hat de l'acte est
divorcée de hilson parade
et puis cet extrait où elle retrouve son
partenaire phalanstère life cost de
maurice dans un époustouflant numéro de
claquettes bien sûr
non
voilà ginger rogers très heureux de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau d'antenne 2
cela fait qu'elle ait fait se revoir
rester ici pour une semaine à français
guillaume invitait de le télévision
excusez moi je parle bien produit bonne
année et me joël pearson à ce que c'est
c'est le première fois vous avez vu tout
à l'heure les extraits des films que
nous avons montré vous vous souvenez de
quelle date ils sont âgés je vois tous
les choses parce que dans une heure et
45 minutes est avec vous uniquement avec
est ce qu'il est un discret de vous
demander votre âge aujourd'hui en
ontario ah ah c'est pas mon affaire
alors moi je sais votre âge ne pas le
dire mais il faut dire qu'à votre âge
vous danser encore aujourd'hui et vous
chantez encore vous allez danser dans
l'émission de guy lux par exemple hayden
à chaud j'ai dansé pour le show pendant
combien de temps et on m'a dit que vous
dansiez très bien je vous ai vu à
londres il ya deux trois ans en tout cas
merci beaucoup d'être donc rendez vous
le 1er janvier sur notre antenne dans
l'émission de guy lux donc voilà pour
terminer la page de la météo aujourd'hui
temps plus doux vous l'avez constaté
moitié ouest et froid et verglas
ailleurs
demain le temps doux gagnera tout le
pays avec nuages et pluies éparses avait
rendez vous avec l'information sur
antenne 2 22h40 la dernière édition du
journal présenté ce soir hervé claude
12h30 c'est samedi et demi la première
édition du week end thème de ce magazine
présenté par jean claude mongeau
les seuls qui en les jeunes qui en
veulent pardon à l'occasion du discours
de valéry giscard d'estaing demain à
paris discours qui clôturera la semaine
de la jeunesse
ainsi s'achève l'actualité de ce 8
décembre au nom de toute l'équipe qui
m'a aidé à préparer ce journal je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de soirée je
vous répète l'information je vous
donnais au courant de ce journal le
voilier repérer n'est pas celui de manou
réf bonsoir à tous alain ici